[Music]
what are your memories of the first
beauty and the beast' well I have to say
that it's been 26 years ago yeah yeah I
do because what I remember from it is
the song that was presented to us I was
at the beginning of my career he put me
on a map and gave it took me where I am
today and
what I was asked to sing this song but
the second beauty in the beasts
how does a moment last forever was like
what what are you doing another beauty
in the bees that could say yes right
away because I felt like I was like
cheating it away like I'll get it
I told me goodbye and yeah I'll tell is
that my first beauty who beats what
decisions must make with my husband now
finding decisions on my own it's a
little harder sure so they gave me like
to think about it and I said those guys
it's because of them that I'm gonna sing
this song for the rest of my life
[Applause]
sing it solo and I love that moment you
just had reconnecting with Alan right
here who of course wrote the song I mean
just off each other since 1991 or 92
actually a full moon that's pretty cool
I guess to see people now we're having a
little fun we're testing people's
knowledge of Disney Princesses she's
always bound yes sir
it's only about because I have three
boys and otherwise it's about fighting
Superman so